well let me ask sort of uh looking back
the six years looking out into the
future based on your current
understanding how hard do you think this
is this full self-driving problem when
do you think tesla will solve level 4
fsd
i mean it's looking quite likely that it
will be next year
and what does the solution look like is
it the current pool of fsd beta
candidates
they start getting greater and greater
as they have been
degrees of autonomy and then there's a
certain
level beyond which
they can they they can do their own they
can read a book
yeah so
uh
i mean you can see that anybody who's
been following the
fossil driving beta closely um we'll see
that the um
the
rate of disengagements has been dropping
rapidly
so like a disengagement b where where
the driver intervenes to prevent the car
from doing something right
dangerous potentially so
um
so the interventions
you know per million miles has been
dropping uh dramatically at some point
the
and and that
trend looks like it happens next year is
the the the
probability of an accident on fsd uh is
less than that of the average human and
then and then significantly less than
that of the average human
so
it certainly
appears like we will get there next year
then then of course that that then
there's going to be a case of okay we
now have to prove this to regulators and
prove it to you know and and we we want
a standard that is not just equivalent
to a human but
uh much better than the average human i
think it's got to be at least two or
three times
higher
safety than a human so two or three
times lower probability of injury than a
human
before before we would actually say like
okay it's okay to go it's not going to
be equivalent it's going to be much
better
you